[music]
moreover, we
really
managed to do something great today for our compromises, namely we
achieved unanimous approval
at this point i would like to go into more detail on two topics, on
the one hand the western herring
and on the other hand the western
German for the  western german
we agreed to increase the quota
to around 9500 tons compared to 2018. for
herring in the western baltic sea
we were able to agree on a sensible
solution that is not far from the
commission proposal and
at the same time avoids overly drastic annual
fluctuations for the fishermen affected
as far as salmon is concerned, we were
even more ambitious than the commission
and agreed on a lower quota
service providers and the
baltic sea
[music]